hey guys what's up square just announced
their earnings for q3 and they have some
big numbers in here 1.82
billion dollars in bitcoin revenue in q3
1.82 billion dollars is a big number
jack was also asked about other
cryptocurrencies and in it they said
will you add anything else to squares
cash app or to the balance sheet he said
no we're not our focus is on helping
bitcoin to become the native currency
for the internet and we have a number of
initiatives towards that goal
also allegedly they are going to publish
in mid-november the white paper for
their brand new bitcoin business
remember jack dorsey his entire focus is
to make bitcoin the native currency of
the internet it is pretty compelling
when you see somebody who is one of the
best entrepreneurs of our lifetime as
somebody who's built two multi-billion
dollar companies that are publicly
traded and saying all i am focused on is
on bitcoin i am trying to figure out how
the hell to make this a native currency
of the internet so square traditional
fintech company they've got tons of
resources but those can serve as either
a tailwind or it could actually be hard
in some way square is having to actually
disrupt itself having to add in these
assets that do not are not supported by
their legacy technologies and so to see
this occurring is pretty damn cool and
so when you start to look at jack's
exact answer and he continues he says we
have a number of initiatives towards
that goal of bitcoin becoming a native
currency cash app is just one we're
going to be building a high roll wallet
with bitcoin mining a consumer device to
mine bitcoin at home or in a business
and our seller businesses in fact and so
again that bitcoin mining a consumer
device to mine bitcoin at home or in a
business coming from square according to
jack dorsey they believe this focus is
important we believe it's right and a
lot of it has to do with the resilience
the fundamentals the principles that
bitcoin offers and we also want to make
sure that we're giving back to that as
much as possible and it also reflected
in our purchase for bitcoin wallet
bitcoin mining and our new business unit
called tbd which is focused on building
a developer platform to enable more
ideas around decentralized finance on
the bitcoin stack and on the stability
that it offers and all the resilience
that's had over the decade plus so we're
going to be releasing more details on
tbd2 uh soon and they've got white paper
coming out and so when you start looking
at this this is not just some random
effort this is not just buying bitcoin
and putting on the balance sheet this is
not saying oh we kind of sort of like
this this is a full-blown effort by
square a hundred plus billion dollar
company trying to figure out how the
hell do they continue to incorporate
bitcoin in their business they obviously
are going to continue with cash act cash
app is a monster 1.82 billion dollars in
bitcoin revenue in q3 but on top of that
they've got this wallet that's coming
out they've got a consumer mining device
and also really important they look like
they're going to start actually
integrating this stuff with some of
their sellers as well so it would not
surprise me to see square become the
largest bitcoin company in the world why
is that well they have tens of billions
of dollars they can invest towards this
they also have integrations both at
point of sale with things like after pay
which they recently acquired and
shareholders just approved but they also
have their pos system they have their
merchants uh tools they have cash app
they have a payroll system they just
have their hands in so many different
parts of the traditional financial
sector that if they start to actually
implement bitcoin or incorporate it in
some way i think that it will become a
very very interesting business now there
is still a lot of questions here this is
not a foregone conclusion you have tons
and tons of execution risk ken square a
business that's so successful legacy
system actually build a mining device
can they build the wallet correctly can
they get it out into the hands well part
of what they're doing is they're doing
this in a very open source way they're
looking for help they're looking for
feedback from the community and i tend
to think that that gives them a higher
chance than not of being successful here
i wouldn't bet against jack dorsey i
wouldn't bet against square and i don't
think that many people who are into
bitcoin are willing to do either as well
so square big numbers coming out in
terms of that earnings report hope that
you guys all have a great night and
we'll talk to you guys tomorrow